ça fait peur le site depuis tout petit
je fais un rêve assez étrange
j'ai deux ans et demi je suis dans le
jardin chez mes parents et je m'envole
et plus je prends de la hauteur plus je
prends de l'âge 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans 20
ans je survole le potager je survole les
arbres fruitiers voix tensions nées en
picardie donc à 3 cerisier de pommiers
le marronnier centenaire la maison de
mes parents et à ya un moment où je
décide de partir en fait à l'aventuré je
décide d'aller découvrir le village dans
le cas de shalit je décide d'aller
découvrir la vie et au moment où je
prends je prends mon départ je me
fracasse contre une vitre invisible et
je tombe je tombe à l'intérieur de la
propriété chez mes parents et juste
avant de me fracasser sur le sol je vois
une phrase énorme marqué en rouge
qui suis-je et c'est vrai que c'est le
genre de questions qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de se poser on doit prouver à
nos parents on doit prouver à nos
professeurs on doit prouver à nos
patrons pour un homme
je fais parler de ce que je connais il
faut être le plus attirant le plus
violent le plus puissant le plus
envoûtant le plus productif le plus
réactif le plus lucratif et sont passés
de rêve de gosse alors moi je vais vous
raconter mon histoire et j'espère
qu'elle fera écho à la vôtre c'est juste
l'histoire d'un être humain qui est
tombé plusieurs fois et qui à un moment
voulu justement prendre un petit peu de
hauteur sur ce qu'il avait vécu et j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être un super héros et
je trouve que le plus intense
le plus intéressant je dirais c'est de
devenir un humain c'est toujours été un
explorateur du possible et au delà du
possible à trois enjeux pour le chat
dans le feu je soulève le canapé du
salon
à 6 ans quand mes parents et mes soeurs
sont couchés je descends avec ma petite
cape de super-héros je vérifie si le gaz
est bien fermé si les portes des
placards sont bien faire mais aussi pour
les fantômes mais je vérifie toutes les
portes et puis après
bush et puis là je peux m'endormir se
ranger protéger ma famille à 7 ans mon
père me fait découvrir le rugby et là je
découvre la mixité qui découvrent la
différence je t'ai prouvent des gros des
grands des gras les petits découvrent
des arabes des blacks
la diversité la mixité et puis à 10 ans
mes parents décident de mettre dans une
école catholique où tous les vendredis à
l'église on m'apprend à croire en annexe
les bras en croix saignant moi je dis
mais qui va prend à croire en moi alors
je suis pas baptisé et je me retrouve
devant le prêtre tous les vendredis midi
à la messe des je ferme les yeux et je
me dis si tu existes vraiment je me
confronter à lui il va me punir et puis
l'homme renvoyé chez mes parents dans
mon village et je trouve les yeux j'ai
l'hostie dans la bouche qui colle un peu
et j'ai toujours l'institution du
saint-esprit à 14 ans deuxième histoire
d'amour le théâtre madame dindar cela en
quatrième qui lui fait découvrir le
théâtre et je suis prête pour vous si
vous vous souvenez justement d'un
professeur passionné et passionnant qui
vous découvre fait découvrir une matière
d'un mois pour moi c'est celle théâtre
je vais faire trois pièces de théâtre au
collège et au lycée
à 15 ans je me fais dépuceler d'enfants
mon jardin en cas en cinq minutes chrono
dans une tente
je vous raconte ça parce que dans le
rugby au début à 20 ans je racontais que
j'avais mis une demi-heure ce avait été
énorme 50 ans cinquante cinq minutes
dans une question ça fera baisser un
petit peu les google à 18 ans je
débarque à paris de ma picardie avec mon
premier amour et le stade français marc
p donc je suis rugbyman je pars dont
deux mâts de mon village en picardie et
je débarque à la défense avec tous les
matins vue sur un cimetière une
autoroute et l'arche de la défense alors
que tous les matins je me levais avec un
arbre fruitier avec mon marronniers un
électrochoc pc l'individualisation c'est
le moment où on part de chez ses parents
où on découvre la vie moi je découvre
paris le stade français décide de me
surclassé dans la catégorie reichel qui
est la catégorie phare des juniors en
france et je gagne un titre de champion
avec des amis des frères qui sont encore
mes frères aujourd'hui j'en citerai
trois pierres salim et rodolphe qui sont
une meilleure amie encore aujourd'hui je
citerai même l'udc avec qui j'ai
commencé le rugby à sept ans c'est
important c'est l'amitié
et puis en 99 bernard laporte et dans
les tribunes
voit cette fameuse finale le 16 mai 99
et tirua où il ya un mental d'enfer un
physique d'acier on va le faire signer
un contrat pro entre 98 et 99 j'ai pris
8 kilos de muscles en un an sans se
doper
parce que je suis dans le bouquin de
monsieur balester aujourd'hui et à soi
disant je me suis dopé ou soit disant
que j'ai fermé les yeux sur je n'ai
jamais vu de dopage et je ne me suis
jamais dopé que ce soit bien clair je
ferme la parenthèse
ça c'est pour monsieur balester on est
en 99 donc je suis rugbyman
professionnel je gagne 18 mille francs
par mois j'ai un appartement je commence
à m'acheter une belle voiture j'ai la
reconnaissance je suis un gladiateur des
temps modernes je suis un dieu du stade
j'ai eu la chance ou pas de faire cinq
fois les calendriers à poil et puis dont
je connais une forme de notoriété on me
voit dieu du stade donc et on m'annonce
comme un des espoirs du siècle les
médias et les titres espoirs du siècle
sans rejette donc j'ai connu les plus
grands stades en france j'ai eu la
chance de jouer au parc des princes avec
des grands frères christophe dominici
entre autres christophe moni hervé
chaffardon je pourrais tous vous les
citer tellement ils étaient énormes j'ai
joué avec sept nationalités différentes
et j'ai gagné trois titres de champion
de france et j'ai fait deux finales de
coupe d'europe et je me suis régalé ça a
été une aventure humaine sauf que ça
c'est pour la part de lumière et dans la
part d'ombré j'ai eu énormément de
blessures parce que je suis excessif
parce que je suis quelqu'un qui fait
tout à 200%
alors ce qui m'a un petit peu marqué
justement dans mon parcours c'est que je
me suis retrouvé vraiment seul dans la
solitude de la blessure et aucun soutien
psychologique au niveau du sport parce
que dès qu'on parle de psychologie dans
le sport ça veut dire faiblesse là j'ai
été faible mais faut du mental je suis
un champion l'heure à chaque blessure je
revenais sous les barres 140 kg en
développé couché il est 23h45 on est le
11 juin 2005
je suis en costard au milieu du stade de
france à 80000 personnes autour de moi
on vient de perdre la finale de
championnat contre biarritz est là pour
moi le rugby c'est fini et je regarde en
arrière je le dise six ans au stade
français 6 finales loupé et six
opérations
gd agra dans cette épaule j'ai une vie
dans cette épaule j'ai une plaque dans
le bras j'ai une couille qui a explosé
et j'ai le genou des français il faut du
mental je suis un champion
bah oui j'ai pu le rugby la plus grosses
cicatrices psychologiques
la plus grosse cicatrice était
psychologiquement et c'est pour ça que
je fais des conférences aujourd'hui en
entreprise et dans le sport c'est que
j'ai un entraîneur qui se disait
soi-disant manager qui m'a dit un jour
way raphaël tu est un super mec
humainement pour le groupe mais
techniquement tu es nul tu es merde et a
pas le niveau pour jouer dans le top 14
la motivation l'importance du mental
et ce n'est que penser de faire du bien
j'ai fait comme ça qu'est ce que je vais
faire de ma vie est bien septembre 2000
2005 je vais être comédien vu que
j'avais ma deuxième histoire d'amour au
collège et au lycée et je fais un an
laboratoire de l'acteur après avoir été
un espèce de frankenstein du rugby me
voilà au laboratoire de l'acteur le 27
juin 2006 la mère tombe malade elle a
une chance sur deux de s'en sortir
je pense à elle aujourd'hui elle est
hospitalisée je l'embrassais fort élan
vous savez c'est ce truc où le moment je
prends une vitre dans la tronche c'est
un maire qui est malade donc la chair de
ma chair et puis je passe un casting
pour marie stuart pour jouer le rôle
d'un apprenti bourreau muer en 1100 en
écosse avec isabelle adjani
donc je prends mes parents sur le dos et
je fais 115 représentations muet
imaginez comme je parle compliqué quatre
mois plus tard je me retrouve le 1er
janvier 2007 avec plus rien je regarde
autour de moi mais ce qui manque au
rugby et ce qui manque dans ces grands
moments c'est pas la notoriété c'est pas
la loi
c'est pas l'argent si la belle
reconnaissance du travail accompli par
ses potes par les gens autour et ça se
passe pareil j'étais à la retraite en
2005 au rugby en même temps que mon père
donc je comprends dans cette société où
il faut pas lire je comprends ce que vit
une personne à 60 ans elle est vécue à
25 et donc à 27 ans je me retrouve à
dire mais qu'est ce que je vais faire de
ma vie quel sens se donne à tout ça les
seuls rôles qu'on propose c'est des
rôles de brancardiers autres videurs de
boîte dans mon gabarit mais j'aimerais
que les gens voient ce qui est à
l'intérieur ma sensibilité
alors quand je parle de sensibilité dans
le rugby c'est eux on n'est pas des
nom n'est pas homo et combien même
si on l'était on parle de respect de la
différence et j'ai cette sensibilité en
moi je veux la comprendre en novembre
2007 décembre 2007 je rencontre richard
escot un autre référent un autre merlin
l'enchanteur
comme cette professeur de français en
quatrième comme cet entraîneur en 2001
kimathi amuse toi et j'étais l'un des
meilleurs à ce moment là hélas ce
journalisme me fait découvrir la
philosophie
il dit pendant 27 ans a été dans le
paraître
maintenant va falloir découvrir l'être
mais l'idée c'est d'arriver à trouver
l'équilibré entre les deux il me tend un
bouquin de luc ferry qui s'appelle
apprendre à vivre les cinq grands
mouvements de la philosophie avec la
nostalgie du passé la peur de l'avenir
et toute la symbolique derrière et moi
le dernier bouquin que j'avais vu
c'était le père goriot en 97 pour le
blog français aidé à la philosophie et
bien j'étais à corps perdu dans le rugby
pendant 18 ans et là je me plonge à âmes
perdues dans la philosophie et dans la
psychologie et je me perds lorsque les
religions appel l'enfer l'enfer c'est
quand on se confronte à son propre ego
en juillet 2008 je rencontre julie une
jeune femme qui elle a 21 ans j'en ai 28
on est deux gamins une histoire d'amour
qui se créent et une histoire d'amour
passion avec un petit peu de destruction
pendant cinq ans en février 2009 je me
retrouve au rsa mais pour moi l'argent
n'a jamais été un véritable problème je
me retrouve à 400 euros par mois
je suis toujours dans cette quête de
sens qu'est ce que je vais faire de ma
vie qui suis-je au milieu de tout ça au
milieu de cette société qui en plus le
vent du fantasme à travers cette télé
réalité et ce sport qui devient business
alors je me jette encore dans la
philosophie toujours encore et toujours
en novembre 2009 je vais travailler aux
restos du coeur alors je pourrais en
être bénéficiaire c'est pas pour vous
faire chialer 1 mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit des gens qui sont pauvres
et qui sont vraiment dans une vraie
pauvreté mais votre dépression elle
passe pour un espèce de conte de fées en
février 2010 je rencontre deux autres
merlin l'enchanteur manuel aguiar et
raphaël mahieu des coachs mentaux je
décide de faire une formation de coach
mental pas pour devenir coach mental
mais pour comprendre ce qui se passe
dans le sport aujourd'hui pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé pour moi
trouver la bonne motivation et il me
parle de l'importance de l'individu
l'importance de la complexité de
l'individu et à travers le coaching on
comprend un peu comment fonctionne moi
je fonctionnais dans l'extraversion jeux
qui fonctionnent et j'avais du rouge du
jaune qui vomissent est partout la quête
de reconnaissance
et puis j'avais 2 % de ce que j'appelle
le bleu la structure j'avais toujours eu
un problème avec l'autorité
bref je pourrai pas tout vous expliquer
parce qu'il faudrait une heure mais
c'était passionnant et à la fin de cette
formation belge devient pas coach mental
mais je comprends un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé pour moi dans le sport et je
comprends un petit peu ce qui se passe
pour les jeunes qui sont dans le sport
aujourd'hui
et qui sont dans une quête mais
aujourd'hui on fait un petit peu de la
chaire à canon et pour la nouvelle
génération je me dois justement de
témoigner vous allez comprendre un peu
plus tard et donc après je me plonge
dans les études de philosophie au mois
de septembre 2000 2010 et là pendant
quatre points on m'apprend ce qu'est
l'amour eros on m'apprend qu'il ya de
l'amour fida et de l'amour à gap et dans
d'autres formes d'amour que cet amour et
rose dépendance ou c'est toujours de la
faute de mana ou de mon mec la faute 2
et on me parle aussi de la hiérarchie de
pouvoir avec les bourreaux les sauveurs
les victimes et c'est vrai que en amour
en amitié et dans le travail on a
toujours tendance à trouver un petit peu
ce triptyque quand on est entraîneur il
fait jouer c'est mon sauveur quand il
fait pas jouer c'est mon bourreau
et puis quand je blackman avais je suis
son bourreau et quand je reviens je suis
son sauveur et je suis victime 2 et
sortir de ça pour rentrer dans la
hiérarchie de compétence qui est on va
travailler ensemble à égalité avec nos
compétences sortie de cette hiérarchie
de pouvoir je clos la parenthèse philo
en novembre en septembre 2011
j'ai écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
quand j'étais superman en collaboration
avec thomas saintourens et tf1 france 2
france 3 france 5 et m6 m'ont fait
passer pour un cocaïnomane dépressif et
alcoolique
m6 a été la totale avec jambon fromage
ça a été les trois le triptyque
sauf que ce que j'ai racontée c'est pas
du tout ça je raconte pas une victime du
rugby française raconte juste un mec qui
est coresponsable de sa carrière qu'aux
responsables parce que la responsabilité
est partagée comme en amour en amitié
dans le travail c'est pareil là il y
avait la responsabilité du club
la responsabilité de la fédération la
responsabilité de la ligue et ma
responsabilité aussi au milieu de tout
ça
dans ce bouquin est sorti il fonctionne
bien super en 2012 je demande à mes
parents de m'écrire une lettre chacun
pour savoir d'où je viens et je
comprends baisse qu'a vécu mon père il
m'écrit six pages je comprends son
enfance son adolescence
l'arrivée de mes soeurs mon arrivée la
musique la passion qu'il a pour le jazz
je comprends aussi le parcours de ma
mère est aussi cette révolution féminine
dans les années soixante dix qui pour
moi est tout à fait légitime et normal
et j'espère que ce sera un jour la fin
du patriarcat
et donc elle nous raconte justement son
parcours nos arrivées et puis et puis je
comprends aussi justement sa maladie
elle est encore vivante aujourd'hui et
ça permet de savoir d'où je viens ça
fait du bien en septembre 2013 vous
savez dans la mythologie en général
c'est toujours une femme qui révèle à
l'homme son potentiel
ben moi ma femme m'a révélé en plaquant
elle m'a révélé en plaques ont pour un
rugbyman c'est vrai que parce qu'elle
m'a dit où était là était devenu un gros
con et c'est vrai alors attention part
de responsabilité partagée je vais
parler de mon cas j'avais aussi sa part
de responsabilité va pas non plus
défendre là mais je laime voilà est donc
l'affairé mais oui part de
responsabilité parce que j'ai été plongé
dans la philosophie dans la psychologie
mais pour me rassurer parce que ça
rassure et je suis devenu qu'on est
dogmatique
parce que le dogme justement c'est
d'imposer aux autres justement sa propre
réalité
mais ce que je ne me rendais pas compte
justement c'est qu'il ya 7 milliards de
réalité est donc là je suis parti dans
ce que une fois de plus la religion
j'appelle l'enfer la dépression
véritable parce qu'à force d'avoir été
sous pression physique dans le rugby est
sous pression psychologique avec la
philosophie ben là je lâche les armes je
peux plus rien faire je perds 10 kg les
émotions vomissent de partout et je me
retrouve le 25 décembre chez mes parents
dans cette chambre d'enfance et là je
peux plus respirer je peux plus rien
faire et c'est l'aveu de faiblesse
c'est le moment juge décide de dire mais
j'ai besoin l'aide et pour un homme
c'est compliqué le 28 décembre
je vous raconte j'ai eu cette petite
anecdote à 14 ans qu'on te bové allait
jouer contre contre clermont ont passé
avec le club de beauvais avec l'udc on
rigolait toujours en passant devant
fidjienne fils james et un hôpital
psychiatrique
on s'est dit bonjour on va finir affi
diable et bien moi à 33 ans je finis à
l'hôpital psychiatrique de clermont et
c'est le moment en fait où je suis mort
et pour moi dans la religion catholique
c'est ça c'est la mort en fait la mort
d'une partie de moi même et puis à
partir du 1er janvier j'avais touché le
fond de la piscine
et puis là 2014 a été une véritable
révolution plutôt que de dire que c'est
de la faute des politiques des médias
des religions ma nana de tout ça alors
j'ai eu de la colère pour tout ça et
puis on j'ai retourné le miroir vers moi
j'y voyais plutôt que des victimes de
tout ça est ce que je suis pas qu'aux
responsables dans les blessures mais
aussi dans les grands moments et donc
j'ai revu mon enfance j'ai revu
l'éducation de mes parents et puis
l'éducation judéo chrétienne avec ta
culpabilité alors culpabilité j'ai mis
de côté c'est bon j'ai compris pourquoi
j'avais porté mes parents j'ai compris
aussi dans le rugby pourquoi je m'étais
blessé pourquoi j'avais joué ce rôle de
sauveur
j'ai compris aussi à travers la
philosophie que j'utilisais après enfin
que j'ai utilisée en 2014 avec
parcimonie et baisse qui est l amour
enfilait l'amour filet c'est l'amour de
l'autre dans sa différence
mais pour aimer l'autre il faut déjà cv
soit même pas aimé son petit est beau
mais s'aimer soi même pour ses
compétences et pour ce que l'on est
alors à la réponse justement à qui
suis-je
je vais pas vous le donner tout de suite
donc en 2014 ça peut paraître très banal
pour vous mais avec cette jeune femme
avec qui je me suis remis en septembre
et on est fiers de nous on a acheter un
canapé on a acheté une table et des
chaises
et puis je me suis retrouvée le 11
janvier 2015
au milieu de toute cette population un
super moment de fraternité pendant deux
heures et puis après tout le monde
retourner chez eux
et puis moi je suis arrivé face à la
république j'ai vu cette jeune femme
donc julie qui chantaient la
marseillaise et je me suis dit oui je
suis quelqu'un de bien et c'est
quelqu'un de bien et tous les gens
autour qui avait y avait une espèce de
mixité il y avait toutes les religions y
avait toutes les origines face à moi
face à cette statue de la république et
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce que je
peux faire maintenant aujourd'hui pour
apporter justement avec tout mon
humilité non pas les réponses mais
quelques réponses à travers mon parcours
mais j'ai décidé de me lancer dans des
conférences en fait donc aujourd'hui je
fais des conférences oui en entreprise
j'aimerais trouver un théâtre pour
septembre sur paris et puis peut
pourquoi pas revenir ici d'air j'ai
décidé aussi de témoigner dans les dents
les dans les clubs de sport et au delà
du au delà du rugby pour montrer voilà
de bien prendre en compte l'importance
de l'individu et c'est pareil en
entreprise c'est pareil sur les
étudiants que j'ai face à moi c'est ce
que voilà c'est de vraiment dire que
c'est ensemble en fait qu'on arrive à
construire le futur et c'est au présent
est vraiment ensemble et aujourd'hui je
considère que j'ai des compétences
mais j'ai pas tes compétences j'ai pas
vos compétences j'ai pas vos compétences
et on a tous des compétences on a tous
des capacités en fait à devenir
meilleurs et je vais conclure en vous
racontant justement un rêve que je fais
depuis peu je suis au milieu de mon
jardin
j'ai 34 ans et je m'envole mais je
m'envole avec un petit gamin tout blond
de deux ans et demi à côté de moi et on
s'envole il ya mes parents qui me font
coucou et puis un moment où je me
fracasse contre cette fuite mais la
vitre explosé je m'envole je m'envole
dans mon village et je m'envole pour
découvrir le monde et à la réponse à qui
suis-je
eh bien je pense que je suis quelqu'un
de bien avec les forces et mes
faiblesses mais avant tout je suis